it's great to welcome back to the
program today Mike rinder former senior
executive of the Church of Scientology
and the C organization also author of
the new book a billion years my escape
from a life in the highest ranks of
Scientology Mike great to have you on
again as always thanks David it's
wonderful to be back so I mean in the
interests of treading some new ground
right up front since the last time
you've been here you know a lot of
things have happened in the world that
don't relate directly to Scientology I
think there's this feeling among some
that the Church of Scientology right now
is somewhat diminished both in notoriety
and maybe in strength because it's not
really in the news as much as it once
was is that a fair assessment or do you
disagree with that oh no I think that's
a very fair assessment David I think
that Scientology has been dwindling as
to its overall numbers and its influence
primarily due to the internet also due
to a lot of media coverage you know
information is the enemy of high control
organizations and groups and Cults and
information is available to anybody that
has a computer or a phone and can Google
and you know these days nobody buys a
pair of shoes without Googling are these
the best ones yeah so it's very
difficult for Scientology to
get new people in and so
their numbers are diminishing but I
wouldn't say that that is diminishing
their revenues yet
because what happens is you get
organizations that are you know in a
bubble of US versus them mentality when
the walls start closing in the people
inside feel more desperate that they
have to do more give more money but like
become more active and and involved in
order to save their particular cult from
Extinction so probably Scientology is
still raking in you know millions and
millions a week but that is an
unsustainable model because eventually
those people run dry and you have to
have new people coming in and that is
not happening and you know you you add
to that the problems that have come up
you know there's been this political
race for the mayor's office in Los
Angeles which is turned into a
mudslinging contest on who can hit on
Scientology the biggest
and the Danny Masterson trial now
started a lot of things uh
are looking pretty dark in the world of
Scientology right about now in terms of
the numbers you know I I in Lawrence
Wright's book going clear
uh right writes that internal claims
often allude to millions of members I've
read numbers as small as 30 000 globally
which which I don't even know it sounds
very low but maybe it is that low what's
your sense of the membership at this
point well my estimate at this point is
around 25
000. oh wow that's the lowest I've heard
anyone even State well there's a few
others uh like who have that similar
opinion
um uh Aaron Smith Levin and Chris
Shelton and Jeffrey Hawkins Jefferson
Hawkins all of whom are former seaorg
people uh you know high level Executives
in Scientology who had access in one way
or another to information about
membership Scientology
inflates the are membership figures by
claiming that anybody who has ever
purchased a Scientology or Dianetics
book therefore becomes a member because
we have their name and address from when
they purchase the book and over 50 years
there's been millions of people who
purchase them so Ergo there are millions
of scientologists but if you look and
see things like
Scientology claims to have 15
000 members in the Tampa Bay area or in
Clearwater right you know the numbers
vary but when Mark bunker who was a a
very avowed opponent of Scientology ran
for city council the Clearwater City
Council
he won with 5 000 votes so they couldn't
round up enough votes to prevent Mark
bunker in their you know Enclave of the
highest concentration of scientologists
anywhere in the world so that pretty
much put paid to any claim that they
have millions of members they they never
have had millions they may have had a
hundred thousand or a couple of hundred
thousand back in the 70s or the 80s but
today no way
you um you escaped in 2007 if I recall
correctly which is roughly like 15
getting closer to 16 years ago do you
think that you were still on the radar
of the church are you being tracked how
closely do they I mean like will people
from the church see this interview for
example that we're doing right now
absolutely David you'll probably get a
letter from a lawyer before you manage
to put this up on anything
um oh boy but but
well it didn't happen with the last one
hopefully so hopefully not this time
yeah but now my book is out so they're
going a little crazy you know they're
they're uh
paying for Google ads to any search of
my name shows up with a Scientology
Google ad putting up new smear videos
and smear sites and sending legal threat
letters and you know all the usual
shenanigans that Scientology gets up to
I'm certainly not gone off their radar
in fact I came like right back into the
center of it the day my book was
released
um one of the things I think is
interesting about your story and for
people who want the details of how you
ultimately kind of changed your mind
about the Church of Scientology and
ultimately left we go into that in
detail in in our first interview one of
the interesting conversations we're
having now is generally about the
deprogramming as the term sometimes is
of people who are in a cult it might not
come as a shock to you that many in my
audience believe that trumpism is a cult
and they see the people at the Trump
rallies uh with with impossible stories
and contradictory beliefs and an
inability to ever kind of puncture the
bubble in in which they they exist and
the question is okay so like what can be
done to accelerate or help people along
in in that process what have you learned
in your experience about what can be
done from outside the cult to help
people in it see the truth or something
closer to the truth well from my
experience it's very tough it is very
tough to penetrate that barrier but in
the case of Scientology what I tell
people to do is use the words of elrond
hubbed as the entrance point to get them
to look you know Hubbard
said a lot of things many of which are
contradictory and on one hand he said
you know do everything that I say and
read and follow it exactly on the other
hand he said believe what you know what
is true for you and look don't listen
and you know uh think for yourself all
of which are very contradictory to the
actual teachings of Scientology but if
you quote those things to a
Scientologist and say look Hobbit says
you've got to think for yourself Hubbard
says you've got to look don't listen
Hubbard says what's real for you is
what's real for you not what someone
tells you is real so don't you have an
obligation to follow what Hubbard says
and actually look at information outside
of that bubble
that has limited success yeah I don't
know David anything that actually is a
guaranteed Silver Bullet there's no no
garlic for this vampire that works 100
of the time time it just is sort of
the one thing I do know that doesn't
work is to tell them they're stupid
right tell them that they're that
they're completely ignorant and stupid
and that they just are our fools because
that plays into their own stereotype
that the rest of the world are the ones
who don't know what's really going on
the other thing that outside not as
applied specifically to Scientology but
that's often mentioned by critical
thinking folks and Skeptics and this
type of thing is that just like bashing
people over the head with facts also
isn't very effective so like as applied
to Scientology that would be like
explaining the scientific and
possibility of some of the origin story
that's told or whatever is your
experience also that talking about the
impossibility of that is not effective
yes oh that that that is useless you
can't approach someone who has beliefs
and try and undermine their beliefs
the only thing that I have seen that
works is the demonstration of the acts
in the real world that are contradictory
to those beliefs like if you take
someone and say you can't believe that
there is a virgin birth
then you're going to have a real hard
time with most Christians convincing
them that there is no such thing as a
virgin birth because they believe that
that is the case if you say that they're
uh look this this uh priest
molested this child and has been
convicted of that and the church covered
it up it's a much harder thing to
overcome that and just go well I don't
really care because I believe in the
Bible
so you got to kind of find the things
that are demonstrable in the real world
that are
and but you know even that doesn't work
most of the time I mean the the
justifications and explanations as to
why things are the way they are or how
they're rationalized can be pretty
pretty out there I mean I see these
people and you know I I watch your
channel and a bunch of other stuff and I
see people that you know JFK Juniors
alive and well and like uh you know yeah
like what
so one of the um one of the things
that's commonly told by people who were
sucked into organized crime is that the
way that they ended up all the way in
started relatively innocuously so it
might start with hey can you just run
this envelope across town for me and
there's this kind of process through
which you're before you know it you're
much further in than maybe you ever
would have imagined yourself to be
similarly you know to to take trumpism
there's a lot of folks who in 2017 if
you said hey you know by 2020 this guy's
going to be suggesting injecting bleach
to treat uh you know a a disease that
you haven't even heard about yet a lot
of people would have said that will
never happen there's no way but slowly
we get there we get their drawing on a
hurricane map with a sharpie and it gets
more and more and more insane do you
find that that takes place with the
recruitment of scientologists oh
absolutely I mean David that's what my
book is about my book is about my
immersion into the the world of
Scientology to the point where I was as
dedicated and as convinced that
Scientology was the only real the only
salvation for all of mankind as anybody
could be I mean I became the the
international spokesperson of
Scientology I was like the head of the
dirty tricks Department that dealt with
the enemies of Scientology I was 100
convinced not that I was doing bad but
that I was doing good that I was saving
the world that I was saving every man
woman and child on planet Earth and that
this was the most important thing that
could possibly be done and
I I hope that anybody who reads the book
will understand the parallels between my
experiences in Scientology and what they
see with other people who act
insane and what were some of the small
asks that that they start with well it
really started for me when I was a child
and my parents got involved and they
started saying to me look the solution
to this problem is contained in what Ron
Hubbard says is the answer to this
problem do what Ron says and your world
view becomes lrun Hubbard solved every
problem of every person on Earth and all
of mankind and laid it all out for us
and if we're too stupid or too lazy to
find out what all those answers are and
apply them then more full us we need to
be dedicated because he has come up with
the answers for everything and as soon
as you start down that
path that there is one person who has
got the answers to everything you then
go into some of the answers and those
answers become themselves the next step
in that immersion process you know there
are a lot of them in Scientology a big
one a huge one is that you have to be
responsible for your own condition and
this is a
you know a platitude that Hubbard came
up with that has some applicability and
validity to it but when you take it to
the extreme that it's taken to in the
Hubbard circumstance it means in
Scientology if you get run over by a car
it's your responsibility you are
responsible for for the condition that
you that you've got yourself into right
and that means that at some previous
time you ran over someone else with a
car right in order to feel the need to
be punished and punish yourself by
getting run over by a car right this is
the ultimate in victim blaming and it is
also the ultimate in no matter what bad
thing may happen to you in Scientology
that Scientology may cause or do to you
it's your fault it's not scientology's
fault right yeah and of course those are
the types of arguments that are
completely unfalsifiable there's
absolutely no way to argue that it that
it's untrue
um the book is a billion years my escape
from a life in the highest ranks of
Scientology we have been speaking with
the book's author Mike rinder Mike
really appreciate your time today thank
you David it's it's great to see you
again